My guest this week is the
singer songwriter Bjorn Ulvaeus.
He's one quarter of ABBA,
so there's not much more I
need to say to introduce him,
but we do talk about what
it's like to be part of
one of the biggest pop groups of all time,
and how he feels about
performing on stage every night
as an avatar while he's at
home in Sweden having a coffee.
Bjorn, it's lovely to
be with you in person,
and I feel like we've just been together
'cause I went to see the ABBA Voyage show,
but you were a bit further
away and you were an avatar.
Yes, and you were together
with my 79 version.
Yes, I was.
But, you know, you did say,
before this show launched,
it was a big risk.
Yeah.
How do you feel about it now?
Oh, I feel so good about it
because it's been a tremendous success
and surpassed any
expectations I might have had.
You know, because, I think
the most important factor
of all is that people who
go there don't see the tech,
but they feel emotionally
connected to these avatars.
What were you worried about?
I was worried about
how the audience would,
you know, experience it.
I was worried, would they sit there
and look at a video because
it is essentially film,
and that would've been catastrophic.
So the first preview was only like 12 days
before we actually opened.
And that's when we knew the truth,
because people did connect.
Is it, I mean, do you find it a bit creepy
or dystopian in any way
when you, especially
for you looking at yourself,
your younger self on stage?
Not creepy, but of course
when I think about it,
it's kind of weird.
In a wonderful way and
not dystopian, I think,
unless people misuse it in the
future, which we don't know.
But used for this purpose,
to tell this story,
I think is wonderful.
And how did it work?
Because it's you, but it's
been filmed with new clothes.
Your bodies have got new
clothes on, I understand.
They look great, by the way.
Designed by Dolce & Gabbana and the like,
how did it actually get created
the avatars as they've been called?
Well, first you do something
called motion capture.
It's when you, as the word
says, you capture motion,
you capture how we move, how we sing.
And you measure- lots of measurements,
All the dimensions.
And the thing is that the skull
apparently doesn't change.
The rest of the body falls apart,
but the skull
remains the same.
And so you capture those movements,
and you scan the whole body.
So that's what we did for
four weeks in Stockholm
the four of us, you know,
actually performing our songs.
And is it, that performance then,
is it your bodies having been filmed now?
Yeah, but body doubles,
with our movements.
The body doubles they
emulated our movements,
sometimes made them much better.
And then we merged those two things.
And with the 79 faces.
So it's a merger between body doubles,
motion capture of ourselves,
and data driven animation,
creating the faces.
And what was it like to be together again?
I mean, I know you've stayed close,
unlike lots of bands from years ago.
You've got a good
relationship it sounds like.
But what was it like being
together, doing this again?
Well, it was kind of strange.
It was a stage, and
they had lots of cameras
but it was like, you
know, doing Dancing Queen,
back in the seventies in some TV studio.
essentially the same thing,
but with four geriatrics.
Is everyone happy with that description?
No but we had fun doing it.
I mean, we looked at each
other and "Wow, what is this?"
Is it emotional for you
seeing your younger selves like that?
You, were in relationships, respectively.
Your lives were very different.
Yeah. It's emotional, but most of all
it's emotional to see how people react,
because there's so much feeling
in the room, in that arena.
It's the right size.
It's 3000, but it feels
kind of intimate anyway.
And people are sometimes crying,
obviously very moved by
what they see and hear,
which is what we wanted to do.
And some of them have come dressed as you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the flares, and in the sequins.
Are you quite happy you're not
in the old clothes that you were in,
that you've been able to be
dressed slightly differently?
These are much more
sophisticated and tasteful.
Some of the stuff that I see that I wore
in the early days, like '74, '75,
I cringe when I see it now.
It's so- but in those days,
it was the glam rock era.
And everyone tried to look
as outrageous as possible.
And yeah, it was very different style.
But it looks beautiful.
I mean, the only other thing
I thought about it is that,
I find Swedes very straight talking.
You sort of say what you think.
I have a Swedish mother-in-law, big fan.
And there is something
about it where is it odd
that you are showing a
younger version of yourself?
Like why not have done
it as how you are now?
What do you-
We're not trying to hide how we look now,
or who we are now.
It could have been a film
with us acting in it.
But we decided on concert.
And we decided it should
be from the seventies.
That made it much more interesting to us,
and I think to the audience as well.
Then to have ourselves
as we are now performing.
So it was just a decision taken,
because we thought it
was more interesting.
Not trying to stay forever young
or anything foolish like that.
Has it tempted, this experience,
the ABBA voyage, the performance,
has it tempted the four of you
to want to go on tour again?
Oh, no.
No way.
No, we toured very, very little.
As it is.
We toured like five, six months,
out of a period of
perhaps eight, nine years.
No, I'm just thinking, you know,
the Rolling Stones keep going.
Yeah, they keep going.
You're not thinking any differently.
No, no.
We never, it was never
an attraction for us
to go on tour actually, that's
why we did it so little.
And Agnetha and I, we had little children.
We didn't wanna leave them.
Do you think this can
be seen as a live gig?
I'm trying to think about
what you've created.
If it is a new genre completely,
or you see it like that?
I see it as a live gig,
as a hybrid live gig.
And do you think-
Because the feeling in the arena
is definitely like a live concert.
Do you think other bands will follow suit?
Perhaps the bands that
don't speak to each other?
I don't know, it's interesting.
I've been thinking about this
and discussing it with
people, who else can do it?
Who else is gonna follow?
I'm sure some of my contemporaries
are thinking about it right now.
I don't know if Mick and Keith perhaps
are thinking about it,
and other people as well.
I know that there's been talk of Metallica
and Barry Gibb has been
to see it, so who knows.
Have they asked you, any of these?
No, no, no.
They just go there and they have-
but it's going to be very interesting
to see someone very creative,
be it an artist or a director or someone,
will go there and and have an idea
of how to take it one step further
or take it in another direction.
Because that's gonna
happen sooner or later.
Is there a gig from years gone by
that you never got to see and
you wish you could have done,
you wish you could have been there,
that could be created by
this sort of technology?
The Live Aid concert in London,
which I think the Queen biopic is-
But it would be so complicated to do
all of these people who appeared
there one single concert.
Well that's a good one.
That is a good one.
It's a good moment, yes.
But the thing is, our
DNA is in these avatars
we've infused ourselves into them,
and you have to be alive
to do that, I think.
Yeah, I was gonna ask you about that.
Because it could become kind of
speculative to bring back Elvis.
It doesn't have the cred that this has,
because we are all four in it.
And that makes the number of
possible acts, artists, less.
Doesn't it?
It does.
I mean, on that note,
'cause I was gonna think,
obviously you think
about the Beatles perhaps
because you know, you've still got,
obviously Sir Paul McCartney performing,
but could you bring back others,
and you sort of answered that,
but would you be happy
for this to continue
after you were not here anymore?
Oh yes.
you would?
Yes, absolutely.
Now it's part of the legacy,
this performance, this concert.
And it will exist for as
long as people wanna see it.
Yes, okay.
So beyond the grave is fine,
if you've been there to make it.
That's why it's gotta have you
involved, the cred for that.
It must be strange as
well sometimes for you,
if you're standing in
the kitchen, I dunno,
having a coffee, knowing
you are performing.
Yes.
You know, I know you still live in Sweden,
but performing in the UK every night.
It's kind of strange.
Of course I've experienced
how Mamma Mia the musical,
our music was played around the globe,
you know, almost 24 hours at the peak.
So, but it's not the same
as having your avatar.
No, it's a little bit different.
And I hope the avatar will appear
in more places than one, quantum physics.
I was just in Singapore
which is a very
interesting place to build,
if that works out, to build
a replica of this arena.
Oh, is that where you're looking to do it?
Yeah, and maybe somewhere
in North America as well.
Okay, multiple Bjorns,
while you're having that coffee.
Yes, yes.
What do you do, Bjorn,
if you are at a party and
ABBA comes on, an ABBA song?
Has that happened?
I ask them politely,
"Would you mind playing something else?"
Do you?
Yes.
And it's like, that is kind of weird.
And I feel, you know, I actually,
I zap when I see myself on TV.
You, change channel?
Yes. I change channel.
Can't watch it.
I don't know why I don't
like watching myself.
Well, most people don't.
They do find it hard
but I thought maybe
hearing it, it might just-
you might start moving.
Well, not when it's
together with other people.
But when I'm in my car, and
I hear it sometimes played
on the radio, I can listen to it.
Yeah, you could drive along, and-
Yeah, yes, and I have to say
that it sounds surprisingly fresh.
A lot of those songs sound fresh still.
If you had to turn one
on in the car, let's say,
Is there one that you always
go for, one of your own?
More than 100 to pick from?
Mm, yeah, 120 or so.
What would I pick if I had to put one on?
I'd probably put on
Slipping Through My Fingers.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, because the scene is so vivid
in my memory from which I wrote the lyric,
from when my daughter went to school.
And waved, and was proud.
And I felt, oh, this is her,
I'm losing her, in a way.
She's doing this on her own,
and she's taking her first steps.
And that situation,
every parent knows that.
It is an interesting time in
music, with what makes money,
what doesn't make money for
new artists coming through.
There's also, if you're
at the very successful end
of course, which you are,
there's the Bob Dylans,
the Bruce Springsteens,
selling their back catalogs
for huge amounts.
And then you've got
almost on the other side
the Taylor Swifts rerecording their music.
So they own them, and own the rights.
What do you make of that
landscape with what's going on,
and people selling their rights
or keeping them even closer?
Yeah, what isn't clear
is exactly what rights
they are selling.
You know, it seems as
though they're divulging
of everything, but they're
probably not, you know,
some of them probably have continued say
in how their songs can be
used and things like that.
But I guess for older
artists and songwriters,
who are really old, it might be,
they make it easy for their kids.
Not to have to inherit it.
It makes it easier if it's cash.
And for someone like Taylor
Swift who's in her prime,
I mean, of course she wants
to own everything herself
and have total control over it.
And so it's different
for different people.
Yes, because I- Yes, we've talked,
you've done other things,
a lot of other things now with the music,
but you've also been very selective,
highly selective about
who's able to sample.
Or use any of the music.
I mean, Madonna is one of the only?
Yeah, she's one of the few who was-
Did she have to beg?
No, not beg, but she sent the recording
with an assistant flying over
the Atlantic to Stockholm
and playing it, because
she didn't wanna send it on
by email, which I understand.
And Benny and I listened
and we didn't have to listen
more than 45 seconds
'cause it's so brilliant.
And we said "Yes, go ahead."
Okay. So if it's brilliant, and-
Yeah, a few things have been brilliant.
Foo Fighters have used Name of The Game
in one of their songs,
brilliantly as well.
But that's about the only ones
that we've allowed, actually.
And we haven't allowed anything
in commercials or anything like that.
Why not?
Because I think that if it's played
in a commercial time and time again,
it kind of ruins a song in a way.
I think that's at least how we've reasoned
and we've had obviously many offers,
but we've said no.
And you know, I mean I
was also thinking about,
because having just seen you
in the seventies, recently,
it's such an unusual band
because of you being in couples as well.
I mean, I don't know if that
has happened a lot, since or before.
No, I don't think the Mamas
and Papas were two couples.
No, no, they weren't.
So there isn't anything like that.
Two couples from Sweden,
leading everyday boring lives
in Sweden and writing songs.
People ask me,
"Why don't you allow a
biopic to be made of you?"
But we've said no so many times.
But I say "No, it'll be boring!"
Do you think there's
anything about the fact
that you were in these
relationships that made-
somebody said to me he was
a big fan of your work.
That they felt that you had created a song
for every part of love, you
know, every almost scenario
of love, whether it's daughters,
whether it's, you know,
with your relationship.
Heartbreak.
Do you think the fact
you were romantically
linked had anything to do
with the ability to tap
into those emotions?
It might have had, now
that you mention it.
I've never thought about that.
But of course so many facets of life
that I experienced through
us socializing as couples.
And within Agnetha's and my
marriage and all of that.
Of course.
I'm sure that inspired
a lot of the lyrics.
And also, one important
thing is that, you know,
we lived in Sweden, in Stockholm
and we were two couples
and it made it very easy to
be disciplined in your work.
There were, you know, if we
had been a boy band based
in London or New York or
LA there would've been
so many temptations.
Whereas we could be
disciplined, we could, you know,
go to work in the morning
like going to the office,
and write songs all day.
Treat it like a job, really.
Yes.
And that's why we were so productive,
I think, during those years.
And we toured so little,
which is also good
because writing songs is not
easy when you're on tour.
So I think that's one of the secrets
behind why we are sitting here today,
is that we could concentrate
on writing so much.
Is there a song you wish you had written,
that someone else has?
Oh there's so many songs that we-
'Cause you probably listen differently
to a lot of people as well, you know,
hearing what they've
done, how they've done it.
No, there's so many good songs out there.
You know, my favorite pop song is probably
Ticket to Ride, with The Beatles.
Is it?
Yeah, but there's Hotel
California and there's Ava Maria,
and there's O solo Mio, and
Smoke Gets In Your Eyes,
so many beautiful songs.
What is it about Ticket To Ride?
I don't- it's like a
compact little pop thing
that is glittering and has the energy,
and all the ingredients.
Maybe it's because I was
such a Beatles fan as well.
Yes, and also, I mean it goes back to
what we were saying
right at the beginning,
which is you have your own memories
which is why you see, when fans cry
when they come to this
concert, this experience,
they'll be bringing certain thoughts
to those songs that you do
because that's what you
associate music with.
And that's the power of it.
And maybe that, you know when I said
about being in the ABBA world,
they'll have a connection
point that just comes through.
Who are you listening to at the moment?
I can't let you go
without asking you that.
Is there someone, it's enough to be new.
it could be, but you know,
what phase are you in?
Actually, I haven't had a record player
for I think 40 years but I
bought one the other day,
a record player, and a real Hi-Fi system,
an old fashioned Hi-Fi system.
Are we talking about with vinyl or?
Yes, vinyl.
Yes, and I listened to
Beethoven's Seventh Symphony.
That was the last thing I
put on before I came here.
So what have you been listening
to your music on until then?
Through your phone, through your devices?
Streaming.
Streaming headphones,
and other devices, yes.
Fine, but how have you found going back
to vinyl all these years on?
Because my partner said she wanted it,
and I went to one of those
shops where they have it
and you sit down in a sofa,
and they play it back
to you, Frank Sinatra
and stuff like that.
And it's, I don't know.
The sound is not better, but
there is something with that.
Did they know who you were in the shop?
Oh yeah, they did.
How did that go down?
They feel a bit of pressure
to make sure this went well?
The guy was, you know, one of those nerds,
and he had to tell me
everything about every speaker
and every player.
And he was a bit nervous, but he was fun.
He was okay.
Because I wonder, you can
go about your business
without people bothering you?
Yeah, I mean, most people,
or many people recognize me,
but very few people bother me.
Okay, but when they do, is it because
they need to tell you
something about the song?
"Thank you for the music."
That's it, that's it!
You did it, you set it all up for me.
Bjorn, it's been such a
pleasure talking to you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
And thank you to you for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.